ich habe den besten Job auf der ganzen
Welt ich Gärtnerin nicht nur selber
unglaublich gerne und Bau mein eigenes
Gemüse an sondern ich bringe auch ganz
vielen Leuten bei wie das geht und hier
seht ihr ganz viele Aufnahmen von meinen
Kursteilnehmern und KursteilnehmerInnen
aus meinem Kurs Gemüsegarten starten ich
finde das so wunderschön dass immer mehr
Leute rausgehen und ihr eigenes Essen
anbauen und aus einer Handvoll samenden
ganzen Garten großziehen und mit den
Händen in der Erde würden und merken wie
wichtig es ist mit der Natur zu arbeiten
statt gegen die Natur und ja ich bin
unfassbar dankbar dafür dass das meine
Arbeit ist das nicht unglaublich